Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
the chapter of tawa chapter number six
verse number chapter
hadith number three in the order of
the narrations of the book hadith number
authored by
[Silence]
Muslim.
Here
narrates that the prophet Sam
used to say often
in his dua, "Oh Allah, I ask you for
guidance and tawa
and
and af FF is
a kind of modesty
but to understand it as only modesty
in one aspect
rather than another is incorrect
is something that we will discuss
inshallah in a moment in more detail and
al and I ask of you
wealth of the heart dignity
etc. This narration has been collected
by im Muslim. Here it's on the authority
of Iben Masoud. What's Ib Masoud's name?
Ibn Masoud's name Abdullah and his
Mhm.
We mentioned him many times
his
Abdman
and he
and he passed away a which year?
Which year?
32. 32. 32 after hijra. 32.
He narrates that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
This word in the science of
okay articulates that it's something
that is recurring
especially when it is paired with what
is referred to as fel
is
present tense or future tense verb. So
he's saying he used to often say this is
how we understand these two words
together
meaning that he often would
continuously
do or say here this is one of his
oft repeated
supplications that he would make saiam
and these are the best supplications.
The best
of all the prophets and messengers are
which ones?
The best of all the prophets and
messengers
prophets and messengers are the ones
mentioned in the Quran. The best of all
Arabic words
are the ones mentioned in the Quran. The
best stories
best supplications
are the ones mentioned in the Quran.
Right? And a close second to that are
those mentioned by the prophet Muhammad
Sam.
It is so
frustrating
to hear in
you know in our time
it is very it's becoming more and
more rare to hear the supplications of
the Quran and Sunnah
being made on the member and in salah
and in w etc. rarely rarely
it's kind of no we have to
reinvent the wheel. People will students
will fall into this mistake as well
where they will memorize the
introductions
of books and scholars
and
fail to mention the introductions
given by the messenger sallall.aii
wasallam. mention supplications,
you know, fancy
, you know, excellent worded otherwise
excellently worded supplications in
books or , you know, by very prolific
speakers but fail to make the
supplications of the Quran and Sunnah.
Those are the best supplications
to the point that people expect it. If
you just lead wit for instance in
Ramadan and you only make the
supplications of the Quran it's like
come on she this guy is a novice you
know this guy is a beginner he didn't
make any fancy supplications those are
the best supplications
they are the highest level of
supplications
you'll hear for instance how often do
we hear the dua of
as it is in the sunnah without any
additions to it. Very rare.
Very rare. It's if it's mentioned, it's
mentioned with a bunch of additions to
it or it's not mentioned at all. And
instead, what do we get?
[Silence]
What is this? ,
right. And the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam
discouraged dua
be made with
when you're standing in dua
you're standing in front of Allah is
this a position to push your chest out
or is this a position to exhibit
loneliness and humility to Allah
It's a position of humility. So when I
start
speaking and proclamations and really
fancy fancy words, how is this
appropriate for the position of dua?
It is not. And that's why the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
discouraged
rhyming,
overly rhyming
supplications.
Dua
meaning overly rhyming
where everything rhymes and everything
sounds very fancy using very strange
very strange words that most people
don't use. This is not a position for
that. This is position of dua. Dua is
supposed to be exhibiting the utmost of
humility to Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
Now you may say well
the dua that you just read by the
prophet Sam
all rhymes right?
Yes, it rhymes,
but this is not by intent. This is often
just comes together that way because
the Arabic language is a naturally
eloquent, wellfitted
language. Second of all, a lot of the
prophet's supplications and even his
statements rhyme or match up in wording
and rhyme schemes to make it easier for
people to memorize. This is by
intention. So is the Quran. It's that
way to make it easy to memorize. Right?
But that is not something that the
companions
would seek out. They would not seek out
to make their rhyming and elaborate
and you know overly complex. No, this is
not a place a position of showing off.
Making dua in front of Allah is a
position of humility. It's a position
where a person tries to embody
to Allah. They try to embody
absolute impoverishment to Allah and his
mercy. And that is what is one of the
prerequisites of dua. He says, "Oh
Allah, Allah
Allah,
I ask you guidance
and I ask you
are very close in meaning
is modesty, but it's not meant to just
be modesty
meaning the opposite of shame. It's
modesty and moderateness in all things.
Modesty and moderation.
Right? So it is modesty the opposite of
shame and it is modesty or it it is
modesty the synonym of of shame that a
person has shame, right? The opposite of
shameless.
And it is modesty
in
meaning mod moderation that a person
is moderate that if a person eats too
much is this?
No. This is the opposite of af. If a
person is showing off is this? No.
This is the opposite of af. If a person
is overly loud or obnoxious, is this
no?
This is all a general meaning of
so is modesty and moderation in all
things. And if a person consumes what
is haram, this is not modesty. This is
the opposite of modesty, etc. You get
the idea.
Alina here wealth wealth what's meant by
it is dignity and
contentment
I ask you for what's meant by here is
that a person is content content
meaning that a person is satisfied with
what Allah has given him this is the
meaning of as the prophet Phetam
said
true wealth is not
a wealth of possessions. True wealth is
wealth of the heart, dignity and
contentment.
[Arabic recitation]